you don't like actors taking naps on the
set you wants to be vigilant and you
punish them yes if you catch them taking
a nap what do you do well to put it the
exact right way is it did always kind of
bug me when you shoot at night and all
of a sudden you see a crew member
sleeping or an actor asleep they always
kind of bug me so I came up with
something where it wouldn't bug me it
would one discourage sleeping wouldn't
bug me and if it did happen now you're
actually happy about it and what I did
is I introduced around Jackie Brown a
new crew member to the set and his name
is big Jerry and big Jerry is a big
purple dildo that's about like this and
about this long like this yeah well no
no it's the ideas it's it's the second
biggest dildo in the store you know uh
you know not big boy just man o'war yeah
we've all been there and so if somebody
actually starts falling asleep what you
do is actually if they fall asleep and
it normally would be a situation where
we give up all right so pretend you be
it's a first all right okay so then
somebody comes in with big chair yeah
you look like a fire right here as close
to the mouth as humanly possible and
before when we did it in Jackie Brown
days we did it with a Polaroid so you
know wake em up oh you guys are so oh
yeah now you can do it with a digital
camera such as like ding ding ding ding
I like that no matter what you're doing
your director all the photos and put
them on a wall of shame I love that
you're thinking about the right way to
get this book on one of them what story
is this telling on garel anyway we got
daryl hannah with big Jerry on a Kill
Bill we I printed shirts the picture of
the dildo right next interesting so and
people people seem to like working with
you again I guess breaking to me they
selling those merchandising yeah